dude what
when you do this jump i said you got to
go i'm going to kick you down
tom cool is amazing you know he
do the jump like over and over
again the scoring king they finished the
movie it's not really good what happened
after that moment
thanks to bessie for sponsoring this
video stick around to the end so you can
find out how to get 25 off of each pair
of bessies
what's up everybody welcome back to
stuntmen react this is a very special
episode not only am i joined by mr g da
silva over here but by the legendary
andy chang i'm andy chen from hong kong
china section
andy is responsible for so many of the
movies that i grew up watching being
inspired by that made me want to make
movies and still today choreographing
and putting together some of the best
fight scenes around right now so it is
an honor to have you here with us thank
you
i wanted to talk about the scorpion king
first this was his first movie right
scorpio it was his first lead rock at
this point is still a professional
wrestler and you have to choreograph a
fight
for him to be able to perform and feel
comfortable performing
you choreographed this fight and it
looks almost like a pro wrestling match
like this is live stuff right yeah right
hands hay makers this is the funny thing
you you're watching it this this is the
we shoot i do the we shoot
this whole movie finished the scoring
king they finished the movie okay they
do the screening test is not really good
then i got hired to do the whole movie
we shoot so for you guys at home
productions at times after spending a
large amount of time making their film
they go out and have it tested they have
audience watch it and they have it rated
and based off the ratings they add
additional photography days so like they
need more action they need a new fight
scene that stuff is then put on the
budget for reshoots and sometimes the
stunt team or even the the actual
production team outside the director and
stuff are not available so other stunt
teams and other performers come in to
fill in the stunt double can be a
different stunt double um the sun
coordinator can be a different stunt
coordinator from the original production
days nowadays big productions like
marvel
dc they already have it in their budget
to have reshoot days already set up so
they'll shoot the production
with 80 days 100 days 25 days but then
they'll have an extra 15 20 days
on the back end just in case for those
days that they need to get
more story points more action points
whatever they need and that's how you
ended up with superman with the mustache
original note in this movie the double
for the rock is his uncle
oh really when i go to rehearsal and
then i do the rehearsal training i saw
a driver you look like at the rock i
don't know why and that's oh wow you
look like him oh i like his cousin i
said why are you not double him and they
said i don't know how to fight you i
said don't worry
you want to do stun do you want to oh
i'm a football guy i said okay yeah so
that's how i that's swap
for his cousin
now we're talking about tunde reid we
have now grown up to see the back of his
head or the side profile of him doing
the rock stunts in movies like fast and
nefarious like anything you've seen up
until this moment from the scorpion king
onward that's this this is his first
movie they see the whole movie he is a
driver right and then we should he
become his name
may the cards have pity on you this is
the fight part that we add we have this
moment i do this moment this is new new
fight scene this is not in the original
oh my god oh my god oh my god that guy
wouldn't
[Applause]
wait
we just saw that jackie like those are
nice yeah
you know because that that's how i come
from yeah right of course you can see
that you know it's a lot of moments
we learned from this master you know
how he how he played with the props and
you know
the locations everything is have to
belong there right
that's pretty sick you're lucky we have
the same bubble
yes
yes so this this so facing the new yeah
it's not in the it wasn't the original
way after this the rundown i got higher
as a
secondary directive
i hope you enjoy the fall now what fall
this moment right after this
these two jump the jeep and then two guy
jump as a physical jump yep and you see
that bush they go very deep yeah i said
let's do this jump down there when i
when i saw them they say what it's a
deep jump it looks scary right but i
said just do this then i do the jump
because you disappear because because
we've done below we have 13 left right
we've already spoken about the story
about the the fall
they said that you you guys had prep and
you're like hey we're gonna go up to the
top of this volcano and i'm gonna show
you guys a stunt you guys climb up and
you guys dig dig a little spot for you
guys all to sit what happened after that
moment same thing i said well this is
sometimes it'll be so much fun and
they're like what
i jump down and then i tumble inside the
glass i disappear
and then
and then on the bottom i pop out look at
it
[Music]
when he do this jump i have to go up
there and say you talk jump down he's
like i said you gotta go i'm gonna kick
you down
so he finally did this one oh he
and this is winning next on the wall
right when i start prepping this scene i
tell them you got a hundred percent with
nomination i don't i winning is very
hard to say right but nomination for
sure
that's such a good way to close it out
oh wait wait into the lens and i put the
look one camera in the water
back then it's all practical right those
cards is all of you
i had a dream tell me on the street deep
below i saw everything i saw all of the
mind players
they've been here looking searching for
something for a number of years waiting
for a special time and place
he has access to a spell powerful enough
to secure them on this plane for eons
and that moment apparently has happened
the psychic blast comes out
30 points of damage and you're stunned
for a minute
as long as you're in here the spells
can't cast through
31 points of damage
this creature is nothing to be trifled
with it is pure evil i need to study i
need to spend hours meditating
i would rather die trying to kill it
you're saying you want to gamble on your
life
[Music]
i've seen this comment many times on the
channel what would be like a corridor
digital made a movie it'd be like this
it'd be like son of a dungeon season two
this is beyond any other project we've
done it's beyond son of a dungeon season
one it's us taking a dungeons and
dragons game a real dungeon of dragons
game and bringing that to life
cinematically and playing it alongside
of the game over the past year this
project has completely transformed our
studio and it's transformed all of us as
well and i can't wait for you to watch
it
all right back to the episode
i want to get into the fight scene
because this was a big fight scene for
me growing up as a kid ernie reyes jr
had always been in my my growing up surf
ninjas the last dragon
ninja turtles secret of the ooze and
here we are
watching him do some amazing martial
arts action
in the school original they don't have
this scene okay so i you know i come up
with the idea of the rock is already so
big
so you have much more big guy to fight
him but we in the jungle why we have a
little guy so i come up with an all
little guy
[Music]
so okay so he there's wires all up on
this guy right now essentially is he
being unwound and run and then and pull
and pull yeah yeah
he gets lifted and then lounge
here's the first one
that's a wrap is the is the rap pulling
it backwards towards camera yeah yep and
then there's a pull
that comes from the kick
[Music]
do we want to do wire work i remember
watching at africa you know those the
natives yeah so we're here on pentecost
island in vanuatu with lindblad
expeditions national geographic and uh
we're at the land divers
they really put the wine on the food and
the jungle right
[Applause]
what
yeah what about your spine decompression
bro oh my god
using this idea to pick him up to fall
into the tree
that's
crazy he's doing this one and then when
we rehearse though
kind of like broke his ankle
[Music]
oh my god and in the rehearsal this is
not this is not even yeah right in the
rehearsal he broke it dude that is
correct man
oh yo how do you how do you do that how
do you do that inside the we shall
everything and then we put all the small
wood chips inside okay so then that's
why i break it and then yeah so
yeah hold on we hollow everything in but
we'll put stuff inside the hole yes so
the gel they have the fire juice yeah he
has the fire gel
yeah yeah
dang that's a good one
yes love that shot so dynamic
very satisfying
and this movie still holds i i can still
watch this movie and enjoy it this was a
great movie i love this movie
[Music]
yeah
then they grabbed him out of the air
dude that's the most smash bros thing
i've ever seen in my life
this kid man
this kid is really good he's like four
years old he stopped doing tv oh my god
he's still performing he's really really
good he's in a human yeah he's in one
yeah
he's a little bit is a student
so are you in the stripes of the suit
you're in a suit
[Music]
he's so fast i'm missing everything
he's supposed to hear
[Music]
dude this move right here
that was that was that was that an axe
kick or was that like this
oh my god
[Music]
95 99
right i was five years old just so just
to give context
i was five years old in 95. bungie young
boy
[Laughter]
so you you worked on sunset mission
possible three only this time only this
scene right here yes
[Music]
but you had a pretty interesting story
about this jump right here can you tell
us a little bit about this this you know
this is the
they should in the universal the parking
lot yeah tom cool is amazing you know he
does it do the jump like over and over
again and you jump down and then they
release the wire walk back
you jump again and then we do like i
think like almost 10 times and then i
remember the director j.j abrams hey i
think we got it no no no just do one
more so he said like
wow but that tells the story he is
really like
into it you know you're into it he just
want to be perfect everything he's going
to get he's got to get this right he's
going to get this together you know
[Music]
so this looks very familiar this
building slide who am i who am i who am
i
so let's go back let's let's let's let's
take a look we got a building slide okay
let's see how let's see how jackie did
it and who am i
oh this is terrifying
so scary this looks a little steeper too
that's much deeper than this oh yeah
this might if you go to rooftop you see
it's just so deep
[Music]
so are there wires in this setup
safety yeah there's a safety line
but then like going back then is like
the safety people cannot see him right
they don't know when they have hiding so
they just that mark you know like you
know that man to make sure he's not fall
all the way to the right yeah yeah even
you have safety
it looks terrifying and he just has such
a fun way of just keeping it
yeah and then he's trying to make it
like right he would make it that's why
he like see him you want to make himself
like tumble slide that's the one to be
just right
which is what we saw with tom cruise's
versions like he's just sliding in to
add action to it he's pulling a gun out
and shooting somebody's watching create
some you know moments if it will be so
boring it'll just straight down i gotta
spice it up and it's just forever like
this is going to forever be
able to be watched and enjoyed and
people would be like oh you know and
thank you so much for that yes thank you
thank you thank you
hey producer jake here i've been in a
lot of corridor videos as a stuntman i'm
no andy chang but i've done my fair
share of stunt falls and stunt hits and
if there's one thing that i've learned
it's that having a versatile pair of
footwear is essential to performing at
the top of your game and courtesy of
today's sponsor bessie that's exactly
what we have for you now if you don't
know vessies are a great on-the-go shoe
that you can wear in almost any
environment they're 100 waterproof
meaning that you can wear them in snow
sleet rain slush whatever and once they
get dirty all you got to do is throw
them in the washing machine or wash them
off with water and you'll get them clean
good as new but not only that bessies
are made from a patented dymatex
material meaning that they'll keep your
feet cool in the summer and warm in the
winter they're going to be perfect
whether you're doing stunt training or
you're on set or you're on an airplane
traveling to your next big production
and those anti-microbial insoles are
going to keep your feet smelling fresh
the entire time and not only that but
besties are sustainably made they use
less material waste during the knitting
process less water waste and they have
no animal byproduct meaning that they're
100 vegan so if you guys are interested
in making a great investment into your
footwear consider going to bessie.com
corridor crew and you'll get 25 off each
pair of adult vessy shoes that you order
just click the link in the description
now my arms are getting pretty tired so
let's get back to that andy chang video
okay all right see you later hope you're
having a great day oh my god oh my
goodness i i just was transported over
the last two hours with everything we
just talked about we we just scratched
the surface andy of your incredible body
of work thank you so much for coming
down and educating us on the history of
stunts if you all want to follow andy
check out andy chang23 on instagram
watch his movies look him up on imdb
he's got a whole list of stuff check him
out watch his stuff thank you thank you
sir so much thank you